[Music]
so my next question is going to be
related to sort of porn and virtual sex
because younger as i understand it i
don't have the the
the direct source or citation for this
but
it seems to be that
that younger generations are actually
having less and less sex and there are
there could be many different causes
there probably are
many different causes but
it would seem to me that in a world of
kind of ubiquitous beauty if people are
able to modify that
and ubiquitous kind of extreme sex that
a certain insensitivity develops right
where the real world pales in comparison
and
you know i follow
vr
less so ar but vr reasonably closely and
i do think you know ready player one is
probably closer than we would like to
think
but
i imagine when you have technologies
like neuralink
and direct direct
you know computer brain interfaces which
could be good for a lot of things but
my my feeling is that you know virtual
sex and kind of immersive porn
is is probably not going to use haptic
suits so these suits
that just have like a vibration in your
chest or something is very dissatisfying
ultimately when it gets to certain types
of things like if you're getting shot by
a ghost in a video game fine but if you
are having sex with someone probably not
the sensation you're looking for but
it's it seems to me that
that as with many technologies you know
porn
is going to probably drive a lot of the
pushing the envelope
yeah
so this is a very
it's like no one will ever admit to
going to pornhub and yet it's like the
fourth most visited website in the world
or something
how far away do you think we are from
that or how do you think about this
because i think the
destabilization that it will exert
not just upon
people productivities the disruption of
relationships possibly uh procreation
putting aside the kind of children of
men movie type scenarios which is a
whole separate thing
i mean that this could even be i could
see it being weaponized where like
they're i mean politicians get involved
because of the sort of macro effects
that these things have maybe i'm just
spinning a science fiction yard but what
are your thoughts okay i'm like taking
so many mental notes as you talk by the
way tim you are an excellent futurist
i want to invite you you have visited me
once at the institute for the future i
would like to invite you back sometime i
want to pick your brain for some of your
wild scenarios because they're they're
informed right you talk to so many
interesting people that you you hear
these signals coming so
let's see okay
so first of all yes definitely porn is
almost always at the vanguard of new
technologies it's one of the biggest
drivers of adopt like sex important will
drive adoption of new technologies
there's a huge interest in neural
implants as you suggest i do think there
is considerable interest in developing
neural implants first wave will be for
mental health for treating
intractable depression and suicidal
ideation that will be the first wave
second wave maybe sex and fun
and you could
definitely imagine a society in which
our
orgasm needs are met
by a neural implant rather than through
physical sex and what i
find
fascinating to think about is you know
could we map out
all of the possible consequences maybe
some positive maybe some negative but
what happens when we don't
have to
have physical encounters essentially to
have and we're already we're seeing that
through porn
but the difference between neural
stimulation is it wouldn't need to use
imagery so i actually think it would be
better in some cases
to get an orgasm through neural
stimulation rather than through porn
because a lot of the porn that's being
created today
is i think really
um
what's the word i want to use there's a
lot of violence
in it that if you look at the research
for why people are younger people are
having so much less sex
the biggest reason that's coming up in
the research right now is that women see
the choking the slapping the hitting in
the porn it's become
normalized and they don't
want
to be choked and slapped and hit they
see sex as more violent than it
traditionally has been and so we've got
this whole generation of young women
who
look at the imagery that's being
consumed and produced and think like i
don't know that doesn't seem
seem like something i actually want to
be experiencing
if we didn't have to be creating these
visual
representations and we could i mean
people might actually come back to sex
if they weren't being shown versions of
sex that they personally did not want to
participate in may i add something to
that yes
because it's all crazy and hypothetical
yeah i know i think a huge part of it
is that
males become desensitized
to
the appeal of let's just call it
everyday or normal sex because if you
can have a threesome or foursome with
like
you know
nubile young women who will
enthusiastically do anything even if it
doesn't include violence and
these other sort of acts of aggression
let's say it's not that let's say it's
just all fun and games but if you kind
of have access on demand to the most
outrageous fantasies that you could
possibly have
instantaneously with broadband i think
there is a desensitization also
i think sex drive from males who are
i think if we want to call spade a spade
typically sort of initiating
interest or sexual advances
you know if if they are constantly
depleting themselves physically there
are kind of physical
self-regulatory mechanisms that will
lower sex drive
so i do think that's a huge part of it
right and it could change culture i mean
if men are just acting differently if
women are acting differently so much of
society is right now oriented around
finding sexual partners
you know our our grooming our our
physical routines our social encounters
i mean like our dreams our hopes that we
imagine for ourselves
if we were to put that
time or energy now let's say but i'm i'm
positing that we're not getting addicted
to this simulation it's highly regulated
in the way that like you can't
i don't know buy
more than x amount of
stimulant medication you know it's
controlled i'm assuming it's going to be
controlled if it's not we're in a lot of
trouble
but you know people like just pouring
their energy
their their male energy their female
energy their their gender energy into
whatever
else they might want to do other than
just trying to find a mate it's going to
be really interesting
like in a way it's as radical as not
having to work 40 hour work weeks and
the time and energy that frees up for
other things if we're not i think it is
so
fundamental that it's
i think it's going to rock everything i
it's because
you know i was looking up the source you
know oscar wilde said everything in the
world is about sex except sex sex is
about power
now put it putting aside the meaning or
the interpretations of the last line for
a second which i think is interesting
but yes that's a whole separate podcast
but it's it's like if you look at
i'll just speak from the male
perspective because like
uh
i mean the vast majority of what men do
in this world certainly up and up and
sometimes exceeding the point at which
they have kids
revolves around
sort of
preferred
mating abilities that's it it's like all
of it the [ __ ] cars the [ __ ] money
the power this is all yes going straight
to sex
when you start to remove
yeah that incentive in the real world
holy [ __ ] oh my god
you